picture this you're out you've had a few
to drink you're heading home what do you
do
tequila kebab kebab kebab the three of
us will be touring the UK but really
just London to three different kebab
restaurant so drastically different
price points to determine which is the
most worth it worth it UK okay this week
I am joined by this profound intellect
short note Nick the kebab king the kebab
asaurus rex kebab Minister Bab Anita
kebab Obama
bring on the babs president kebab right
let's put into all of whatever this is
what makes you an expert quantity I have
had more kebabs than people have had hot
dinners it's late meaty and there's a
lot of chilli sauce first up we are
heading to the woody grill in Camden
Camden is famous for Joe drugs it was
[Music]
today we have the pleasure of green you
guys that woody grill and Cameron town
my name is Kenneth I'm the manager here
we do great collabs
he's the kebab king I'm sure you've
heard of it I have yes yes
the meets comes in there were standards
choice of two sources chilli or garlic
of lettuce onion tomato red cabbage and
the famous pickles meat comes in daily
we use milk as a base ingredients
marinate the meat in various spices
black pepper white pepper chili flakes
following day is on to a spits cooked in
front of a grill the cutting of me is a
skill the archer is to get it as thin as
possible that's when you get a better
taste salads cut fresh nice and crisp
flour based tortilla wraps made daily as
well the sources are a family secret
keep our cards close to our chest almost
you've got the odd occasion when people
asking for ketchup and make a verb as
well no choice Lisa remember that you
had a kebab the following day to do that
you need the chili sauce there we go
you're having the land on a rat the five
pounds of fresh food aren't there wrong
deciding on where to enjoy our kabob
Jowett she had a fantastic idea why not
have it on a boat thanks Joe good idea
so the kabob I am absolutely ravenous
right now the smell of it intoxicates it
and funnily enough I'm not intoxicated
and we are about to enjoy kebab
it looks amazing we did order everything
it's a cocktail of kebab kebab hotel
Cheers instantly taste the freshness
that is really soft and tender in the
middle first bite tends to be the
biggest the meat is so good it's
consistent meat distribution throughout
the kebab I'm going in again there is a
lot more color than I anticipated in
this kebab it is a rainbow in there and
it's a rainbow my mouth pickle is
exploded in my mouth I did not see that
coming
I think I heard the pickle there's the
tickle yes pickle not the tickle the
pickle with the tickle collects anything
here at the bottom where you started
with your Brady aperitif you then travel
through this journey hitting the pickle
before you end with a very saucy box
with a saucy bottom yeah if I wanted to
go to kebab then I got this I would be
really really pleased with myself very
mobile kebab back time about facts time
kebab time think about that time kebab
act time the word kebab actually comes
from the word kebab is a Persian word
meaning fry really yeah is that true
fact yes
go from up there
nothing about this place screams like
late-night drunk food that's where I
first learned about kebab
I still go and have those kebab
sometimes I'm not knocking it
[Music]
my name is Ed Brunei I'm one of the
founders of the Bob here in Guinea
courts over fundamentally what we wanted
to do here was bringing kebabs back into
this mainstream dining see these really
high grades of meat and vegetables the
paneer kebab the only kebab we never
changed it's a vegetarian dish super
popular we start with the bread onto the
grill it's eurie nice char next thing is
the paneer back packet in the tikka
marinade and Grill it over the coals it
gets this amazing springy but soft
texture beetroot puree will bake the be
true blitzed up with extra virgin olive
oil put some coconut flakes makes a hope
of ever zing crispy onion rings finally
they are the crispier we can get them
fried slowly is that batter yes really
they can crunchy visually it's bright
purple and yellow and red and such a
riot of flavors what would you recommend
as a drink to pair with that or a smokey
sour goes really well out of this rose
from below so today you're gonna be
having our paneer kebab at a price point
of 11 pounds looks incredible it's open
let you know what's inside it before you
bite in I never would have associated
this with a kebab the restaurants really
pretty it feels almost like a little
Parisian cafe or so yeah doesn't
impressive about this I think is all the
colors that he was talking about paneer
just looks so good
which on a date snow can fall overboard
with your friends free-for-all
what would you class this I would say
it's somewhere in between the tricky
thing here is they're leaving the
rolling in your responsibility if you
pulls this up you only have yourself to
blame
don't pretend you have a completely much
time we can edit that out so everybody
cheers Cheers
that was really good
unlike any kebab I've ever tasted before
it's really full of flavor the cheese
crispy on the outside soft in the middle
perfect texture and that teak that comes
through a little bit it's not too spicy
the crunch of the onion rings is amazing
I don't feel like I wish I had iceberg
with more onions I spray this is a
really full body meal isn't it but the
beetroot in this is the colors again are
incredible and actually similar color
scheme to a cocktail recommended
cocktail
oh my god I can understand why that is
their most popular dish I think is the
sort of dish that I will now crave
always order than me would you order
this I would 100% all of this I would
never have picked it off the menu
but having tried it the flavors are
amazing scissor is a winner it was
awesome now on our way to one most
expensive about drunk time kebap joke
time I went to an expensive restaurant
Holliday got told the chef special
didn't think he was that special it's
all right he's okay we are now on our
way to our most expensive option which
is in Canary Wharf it is called hazard
[Music]
Spencer
[Music]
my name is Aslam dodgem Alam the manager
of this restaurant we are in Hazare
Canary Wharf especially we don't
recommend when you are drunk come an
order here royal kebab because it is 925
pounds that we share in our culture we
cook and so kept up to our special guest
on special occasions but in the UK its
reputation is more midnight snack I just
want to change this image
do you have chilli sauce of course we
have you will be eaten today royal kebab
created by our head chef
my name is beg suit I'm a head chef on
the top Wagyu beef made only in Japan
the animal itself listens classical
music a couple of salmon day having
massage so soft and melts in your mouth
we make a meal out of it at some very
finely chopped onion peppers parsley we
use herbs cumin oregano salt and black
pepper on the bottom we will be using 21
days all goat meat including morel
mushrooms and fresh herbs like thyme
tarragon third dish is salad every
single thing that goes in it is organic
purely this is what makes it unique not
gonna taste like ordinary kabob products
used in it are so fresh so nice it's
gonna be melting in your mouth
today you will be having royal kebab for
925 pounds per portion Wow I'm in the
king's throne you're in the Queen's
throne I'll take that I feel like we're
in a chamber of meat do give us the best
chairs in the restaurant look at this
chair in Camaros
Oh massive it's like four weeks in Spain
we could fly to Turkey and buy a kebab
and come back and this is for one person
or two well then we'll do what the
Egyptian Prince does
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
which is
[Music]
eyebrows
mmm I can taste the classical music I
think it was probably Mozart perhaps the
eighth and there's definitely something
in there is really lovely meat really
tender really soft you do not get Wagyu
when you go to a kebab shop is how they
justify the price and my god have they
justified the price
[Applause]
I think I'm about to try the first posh
mushrooms
how are you saying that Maura I've also
heard it pronounced morale well there's
no consistency in our browser this
mushroom so I'm just gonna say morale
I'm surprised there's any funghi in
there at all cuz we were in the kitchen
they said there was a mushroom we just
had a moment Linda
whoa that wine is lovely with this zingy
salad we're never caught anything in my
life is dingy but this salad is zingy do
we need bread a big thick pitter would
be too much you know what I think
they've nailed it I don't think you need
bread with this a bread here really is
the goat the goat replaces chili sauce
bread regret it's all replaced by goat
honestly gonna ask for goat in my next
kebab Jonny COGO but you mean you don't
have any goat what sort of establishment
is this how much of your kebabs sure on
a throne yeah but this platter of kebab
in front of us I think this is truly as
royal as a kebab could get worth it
wintertime all the restaurants were
incredible but we have to decide which
was the most worth it close runner-up at
the woody growth very authentic however
for me my worth that winner wasn't about
very tasty very reasonably priced unique
type of kebab bear never had something
like that before
I loved her Zeb and yeah woody grill was
so good but I have to agree with you
live app that against my worth it winner
I never thought I would have loved to
kebab without meat in it I could eat
there every day yeah I loved it there's
no real elegant way to eat a kebab is
there I think I mean quite elegant
mm-hmm okay who told you that
[Music]
[Music]